sorry baby
move over Alanis Morissette this might be the
ultimate diss track Colombian pop star Shakira
has racked up over 82 million views within two
days on her latest music video becoming the most
watched new Latin song on YouTube within a
24-hour period the track takes aim at the
singer's ex 35 year old former footballer Gerard
PK over his alleged relationship with a younger
woman singing You traded a Rolex for a Casio the
song also implies that PK left her when Spanish
authorities accused the singer of failing to
pay 14.5 million euros in taxes between 2012
and 2014 a trial date has not been set but the
45 year old could face prison time in a hefty
line of 23 million euros if convicted
PK has not issued a formal response to
the diss track probably won't respond with
another song probably not I would think not
wow I got to say Michelle has nothing
yeah that's bad I got to say all right